In this question, the number of triangles doesn't matter. Since the number of
vertices lit and the number of pixels lit varies directly with the number of
triangles. But it's a bit confusing to just think about five triangles. So I
like to pick a big nice round number. Let's say 100 triangles. 100 triangles
times 3 vertices per triangle gives 300 vertices. We know that each vertex's
material calculation will be shared by 5 triangles. So that gives 300 vertices
divided by 5 triangles that are sharing a vertex. And that gives 60 evals. In
other words, 60 material calculations that are needed. For the fragment shader,
where we're shading per pixel, there's no sharing. So 100 triangles times 60
pixels per triangle gives 6,000 evals. In other words, 6,000 material
calculations we need to do. 6,000 pixel evaluations versus 60 vertex evaluations
gives a ratio of 100 to 1. As you can see it can be considerably more costly to
evaluate per pixel than per vertex. Note that this doesn't mean that the program
itself runs 100 times slower. There are mitigating factors and other parts of
the pipeline can be the bottleneck. Which changes this ratio on practice.